willkommen auf dem youtube-kanal des
philosophischen jahres einer der
ältesten philosophischen zeitschriften
deutschlands
hier finden sie aktuelle informationen
zu den neuesten heften und den themen
die uns bewegen das philosophische
jahrbuch veröffentlicht aufsätze
berichte und rezension zur ganzen
bandbreite philosophischer forschung
außerdem veranstaltet es in regelmäßigen
abständen jahrbuch kontroversen mit
international bekannten philosophen und
philosophen das gesamte heftarchiv des
jahrbuchs von 1888 bis 2009 finden sie
zum herunterladen und recherchieren auf
der internetseite
[Musik]